notre invité nous y voilà madame john
baez qui depuis plus de 25 ans mais son
arrêt sans talent au service des droits
de l'homme
john baez qui était hier soir au théâtre
des bouffes du nord à paris l'une des
vedettes de la soirée organisée par le
mouvement dit du 21 juin
cette manifestation était d'ailleurs
présidé par madame mitterrand et en
présence du premier ministre une soirée
qui était bien sûr consacré aux droits
de l'homme lors john baez vous faites
partie de l'organisation humanitaire
internationale
en quoi consiste votre action
principalement avec cette organisation
je m'arrête s est une organisation pour
et qui travaille au profit de
l'ex-romain mais c'était basé un peu sur
les choses que que moi seul peut faire
des fois et lorsque je suis très
privilégié de rencontre toutes sortes de
personnes par tout le monde
entre les les pauvres jusque les plus
riches et puissantes aussi alors vous ne
vous contentez pas bien sûr de militer
aux états unis mais vous unités dans
tous les pays du monde où les libertés
sont agressés et opprimés et vous allez
même jusqu'à apprendre des chansons de
ces pays ont cessé de chanter en
plusieurs langues
mais le point le plus important pour ne
sait qu'une chose que je dis en très
souvent et ça c'est très très important
de voir leur pression par tous avec les
deux yeux et ça c'est pas pour moi parce
que pourquoi hier soir c'était très
important parce que c'est pas souvent
que personne très haut dans les gags
gouvernement veut ou peuvent voir leur
pression des différents pays avec
égalité jeunes baisse vous avez beaucoup
lutté contre la guerre du vietnam
notamment sur tous les poèmes de
l'indochine et maintenant vous vous
battez essentiellement pour la lutte
contre l'apartheid en afrique du sud ce
n'est pas votre seul combat d'ailleurs
je pense que les choses peut-être le
plus important maintenant pour humanitas
et pour moi c'est le l'éducation pour
tout le monde au sujet de désarmement
parce que si les deux grandes puissances
ne commençait pas de parler
de considérer ralentir le plus court
d'armements
c'est ce n'est pas la fin pas du tout
parlé de le pen de droit aux mains de
désarmement de de la vie de la
continuité de la vie dans cette panne
est bien madame je vous propose
maintenant de regarder l'extrait d'un
film que l'on avait déjà diffusé à
l'antenne de midi avec armand gatti il
s'agit de d'afrique du sud et vous allez
voir que les femmes les travailleurs
noirs sont pour une pour employer cette
expression quelque sorte parquet
dissimulé prévu en cas d'émeute sont
contrôlés électroniquement
il ya une prison et une seule grille
d'accès gardé 24 heures sur 24 par la
police féminine
c'est là par taille idéale où les
travailleuses noirs ne sont que des
unités de production considérée comme
dépourvue de tout besoin
carole mokoena fait le ménage dans un
hôpital pour blanc elle gagne 100 francs
par semaine pour 60 heures de travail
elle vit dans cette chambre depuis
quatre ans avec trois autres femmes
homosexuelles
même si la domitienne et wasquehal à
double coque noire week end sympa tout
ça des toits a lui battu à f/2 8-5 soit
un quart des territoires c'est comme une
hypothèse n'a pas évité bonnet qui fait
ce qu'on fait sur leurs droits ont été
tuées certaines fautes et john baisse
vous n'allez pas arrêté je suppose de
militer pour les droits de l'homme
c'était un combat permanent et qui va
encore durer 1 et je pense que tout le
monde allait droit de te fais un choix
aux en veut travailler
il y a des plaies c6 et ceux d'afrique
c'est sibérie cissé guatemala cc el
savador afghanistan beaucoup de beaucoup
de monde a besoin de nous et c'est
simple via nouvelle vous écouter chanter
puisque c'est votre art et votre talent
et que vous le mettez au service de
votre combat pour les droits de l'homme
vous allez lui chanter une chanson
française d'un auteur français boris
vian tel est le titre de cette chanson
c'est à tous les enfants qui sont partis
le sac au dos nous vous écoutons jaunes
d'oeufs
marco
vous
2 les enfants
son parti le sac au dos par un bruit
mais matin à vrai dire je voudrais faire
à tous les enfants qui en plus ré le sac
au dos les yeux glissé sous leurs jetons
je voudrais faire un bon vivant
pas depuis hier pas de béton ni de
bronze qui devient vert cela morsures et
de temps
aman iman valeurs sûres comme dans un
monument
eux aussi de leur étonnement
voilà le monde de parfumer plein rire
les oiseaux bleus
la griffe d'un coup de feu un monde où
sera encore qui va tomber
grandis une tache de sang
douce
ils sont restés les pieds d'eau chaude
sous leur bureau en calculant leur en
demande de la guerre qu'ils ont voulu
à tous les cra tous les cocus qui
ventripotent
avis et coton dégoûtant
ou cela
j'ai très serré le monument
les monuments qui leur convient avec la
chaleur avec l'époux et avec mes pieds
avec mes poils
avec les mots qui colleront sous leur
propre lit sous leur va jouer les
marques dans
l'ensemble de boris vian merci madame
venez nous rejoindre parce qu'avec votre
guitare vous chantez depuis plus de 25
ans éditeur d'ailleurs vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure qu'on vous la voler une
fois oui c'était vous allez une fois
mais bon mais quand soeur j'ai dit s'il
vous plaît si vous avez ma guitare joué
le jeu et bien si vous ne lui pas s'il
vous plaît sein des back to me un livre
vient de sortir sur vous et s'intitule
john baez s'est passé pas tellement sur
la chanteuse c'est sur la chanteuse et
la militante vous l'appréciez ce livre
qu'on a fait sur vous à cette un bon
livre et j'ai de test la couverture oui
les couvertures mais c'est 7 septembre
via merci madame d'avoir accepté de
devenir antennes 2010